We're going to finish up this unit with the summary of how to use coverage
to help us build better sotfware.
We're going to have to start off doing a good job testing and there's no way around that.
The next step is to measure the coverage of the test using some coverage metric
that is appropriate for the software that you're testing.
If the coverage was pretty high, let's say 80% or 90%, then what we should do
is use the feedback from the coverage tool this feedback to improve our test suite
then measure coverage again and if the coverage results were poor,
let's say maybe we've only covered 20% of the statements in our code base,
that's the signal that we need to rethink our testing charting.
Of course, if should be the case that we're perfectly happy with poor coverage.
There are plenty of scenarios and for example, web application with element.
We don't need good coverage because our users are going to test the code for us,
and for breaks, we'll detect it by looking at error logs and we'll be able to fix it on the fly.
On the other hand, if we have poor coverage results for some sort of Avionics software,
or automotive software, it's going to be deployed and that's extremely hard to update,
we probably need to rethink our plan in a really serious way
and try to come up with a much better test suite in order to get a higher level of coverage.
If coverage is used in the fashion that I've outlined here, it can give us a pretty significant
amount of bang for the buck, regardless of the result, regardless of whether it's giving us a little bit of feedback
to get the last 5% or 10% of improvement and coverage or whether it's saying that
our testing strategy really isn't very good, it's telling us a useful information.
It's telling us a useful information we probably need to know
if we're going to create a high quality software.
And finally, I just want to finish up with a reminder, so we strongly believe
that if we have a good test suite, and we measure it's coverage, the coverage will be good.
We do not believe, on the other hand, but if we have a test suite
that gets good coverage, it must be a good test suite.
And the reason that, that it's not true, is that it's really easy to take a test suite
and tweak it until it gets good coverage without actually improving the quality of it very much.
To finish up, used in the right way, coverage can be a relatively low cost way
to improve the testing that we do for a piece of software.
Used incorrectly, it can waste our time, and perhaps worst, lead to a false sense of security.